oh my god you like it no it's usually my
mom that does my hair not my dad you do
it okay all right the ponytail I love it
the only thing I know how to do if it's
just me at home then I'll take a stab at
it generally pretty comical I think it's
gonna try and brush my hand that's gonna
fail you don't like when I do you here
wanna he can't do it I think he can do
it I'm feeling confident I can do some
basic stuff I think but you got some
wild stuff here I've never even seen I
do like it and Pony stuff but then once
in all I let my mom do a braid think it
could go great that doesn't sound that
bad five minutes I'll show you how to do
this huh I accept challenges greatly
let's do this dad start with the bottom
this is gonna take me five minutes on
its own got it make it get back no more
like that cuz you know we got to get it
going I want to put it in a pony purse
and then and then put it into three
pieces
oh yeah we'll do a little quick pull
back here God make sure her curls annoy
lattice is moisturize you know that's
what my mother told me feel like the
girls Popeye the little bun no it's good
like olive oil you know you might need
to chop your hair completely off after
this is done oh my goodness
oh they're scissors do this every day is
coming off that single-parent lifestyle
that's pretty good you have to curl my
hair so hard doesn't I don't work either
this is so much let's do some type of
babies like big hair
what what's my time look like stop
pulling on my hair not even know the
purpose of these yeah I'm coming back to
you no no don't we can we get some edges
Goins the guy that he did that cuz I'm
night that's why I can't believe I
couldn't do this really hard boom boom
that's my girl
beautiful this is definitely the roy
braid oh there's a time ahead of
schedule it felt like trying to juggle
and not knowing which ball has to go in
reach and be totally baby
thank you look thanks little confidence
there daddy get a deeper trying thank
you videos on youtube that's actually
two different shout out to all parents
who can do their daughter's hair
hopefully you might have learned a
little something from me whether it be
positive or negative
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right here we go Tracy thank you
[Music]